what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
another darius
m video um it's called 40 year old woman
are afraid to tell you this
i'm i'm only 24 so we're gonna see
what exactly they have to say before i
start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe especially hit
that subscribe button i'm trying to hit
15
000 followers this month okay
there's a saying you can't teach an old
dog
new tricks oh no i already don't like
where this is going
women in their late 20s 30s 40s 50s
they think they run the show they think
they know everything
they're unmoldable untrainable
unteachable
misindependent they don't need a man
their tits are sagging the reproductive
eggs
are drying up their hair is thinning
older women are spoiled milk
bitter angry cat moms
dog moms yes
why would you want to commit or take any
one of them serious
they rolled the [ __ ] carousel all in
their
teens and and 20s now they're ready to
settle down
see feminism has sold them a lie
i was about to say this is the result of
feminism
like men that are angry at the way that
they've been treated
by these women they told women you can
sleep around like man
you can date like man you can take your
time
literally they know women age like
spoiled milk
men age like wine some guys
some guys lake
in their 20s see women don't understand
that
men could care less about their
accomplishments their achievements
their degrees men are into looks
beauty and fertility but women seem to
think you know i got this degree
i've accomplished this goal this is
going to attract it's interesting
because i've actually been asking like
some of my
like guy friends questions like this
about what they care about
and i i have no doubt that like
you know beauty is one thing but most of
them said they really don't care what
age a girl is
like and i asked like i have a brother
that's making like
not half a million but like i mean like
400
300k and so it's not like cheap right
and he literally said he didn't care um
as long as she's like
four years plus or minus a couple guy
friends that are babying like
80ish k range and
it's just interesting because the guys
on youtube will tell you like
that's you know guys care so much about
that and i'm wondering like why
is that not what i'm hearing when i ask
me to a man
wrong they're on their third or fourth
career change
yeah since they can't find a man
that has resources and means they have
to continue to switch careers
so they can survive and they become
bitter
bitter and more and more angry this is
the mind frame of today's older woman
late 20s 30s 40s 50s i know you see it
they think they don't have to change at
least a woman in her
teens and 20s you can mold them they
have a blank canvas
older women they have you really
shouldn't go into a relationship trying
to change people though
if the person you're marrying isn't
someone that you could spend the rest of
your life with then you should not marry
them
so much emotional damage failed
relationship
after failed relationship after failed
relationship
there's nothing changing them no
see older women they think they can do
no wrong they think they're perfect
god's gift to mankind this is true
especially like
this is this is what is the result of
feminism
and especially like the i don't need no
man types
he's talking about a very specific type
of women
and yeah it's that's what feminism
and the media is selling them the media
is telling them you have the fountain of
youth you can take as long as you want
to settle down
chase your dreams girl go ahead then
they become bitter and angry
because they can't find the perfect mate
listen man look out for these older
women too
because yeah they give you really bad
advice
older this is what i noticed was the
women
that are encouraging you to like do what
you want with your body sleep around
whatever like they're the women
that tend to be alone or in
relationships where they're not happy
because i what i've noticed ones i've
been with in the past
they try to get you to have unprotected
sex
pressure you they do they want you to
give them the baby
little do they know that the baby can
have many help complications
like down syndrome yeah
listen guys don't get with older women
these
cougars that you think is gonna be
submissive and
and no these women are uncoachable
untrainable
they are angry they are bitter cat moms
spoiled milk rotten eggs this is what he
doesn't realize
80 of men aren't getting any
so to act like those girls have no
options just is not true
i mean it depends on the girl right but
a girl that's like
30 in shape but just 30
like she probably has options do you
want to take that serious
do you want to invest your time in that
she's not you're not even getting her in
her prime years
she gave her prime years to the bad boys
chad pookie ray ray
and tyrone's yeah you will see
you wouldn't be her first choice she's
just unable to get the bad boys
and attract the bad boys like she used
to yeah but
is she your first choice like that's
what happens
in dating like
like i doubt she has every single thing
you were looking for too
so now she's settling in a way and she's
angry because she has to settle
for you a beta male semp
listen man don't be that guy
they come with a lot of damage a lot of
hurt a lot of baggage
older women are spoiled milk
like the video share
yeah this is it's really sad to hear men
like talk like this
like honestly i mean i get where he's
coming from i can totally see where the
result is it's definitely from feminism
but and it seems like it's a lot of like
the angry women that wasted their 20s
not dating seriously and you know
wasting their time and overlooking like
the good guys
but it's like
a lot of guys have wasted time on girls
that weren't worth the time a day to it
goes both ways
anyways let me know in the comments if
you agree or disagree don't forget to
like
comment subscribe share this video with
a friend i'll talk to you guys next time